three two one and liftoff the rise of
Starliner and a new era human space
flight this morning Boeing launched its
new passenger spaceship on a critical
test mission that could revolutionize
American space travel but the star
liners first uncrewed flight has
encountered a big problem on the way to
the International Space Station
mark Strassmann watched this morning's
launch at Kennedy Space Center in
Florida mark what happened good morning
31 minutes into the flight there was a
problem star liners on board engines
that fire automatically did not push the
spacecraft into its planned orbit and
without that engine burn star liner will
now not dock with a space station after
all instead the new plan is to bring it
home early and have it land in New
Mexico as early as Sunday morning and a
orbital insertion burn has been delayed
with the Starliner flight now in
jeopardy mission controllers in Houston
have a problem again teams here on the
ground er are evaluating their their
various options looking at what the best
next steps for Starliner might be and no
one's following star learners test
flight quite like these three astronauts
Boeing's Chris Ferguson and NASA's Mike
Fincke and Nicole man straight-line of
Houston come check okay that sounds
perfect for you clear as well in this
simulator in Houston they're training to
become star liners first crew to ride
into space but first Boeing was proved
to NASA that Starliner can dock to the
space station and return safely to earth
you got to go from 17,500 miles an hour
to zero and you got a break through
there its atmosphere along the way heat
shield is that working for us and then
parachutes working so this is going to
be exciting flight and we're gonna be
glued to our TV sets
when liftoff the final liftoff of
Atlantis since the Space Shuttle retired
in 2011 nASA has needed a new American
way to ferry its astronauts to and from
the space station
it hired two companies Boeing and SpaceX
to build and fly a new generation of
spacecraft but both are more than two
years behind schedule it's overdue NASA
Administrator Jim Bryden Stein we want
to meet a very aggressive schedule but
if it's not safe we're not gonna meet it
and I'm not gonna apologize for that and
our agency isn't gonna apologize both
companies have faced technical problems
in setbacks during an otherwise
successful test of star liners abort
system last month only two of the
spacecraft's three parachutes deployed
it was human error one was improperly
connected how is that not worrisome well
it is worrisome make no mistake so one
of the reasons we do the testing is to
make sure that those mistakes don't get
made make them early fix them and move
forward but we are going to move forward
the delays have forced NASA to spend an
extra billion dollars buying Russian
Soyuz seats for its astronauts and
liftoff but next year Russia will scale
back those flights putting NASA in a
bind if neither American company is
flying astronauts by April the space
station's crew will drop from 6 to 3
leaving only one American on the 100
billion dollar lab can you do
significant science when the crew levels
drop that low it gets more difficult we
can do some levels of science but if we
have one crew member on the
International Space Station most of
their time is going to be dedicated to
operating the International Space
Station space is hard and it always will
be
well we do feel a certain amount of
pressure to get the job done there is no
pressure to launch this is a very
difficult process it's going to take
some time and I tell you when they find
something here on the ground something
wrong with the vehicle I feel a little
bit relieved I'm glad they found that
now and we're not finding that in space
today's test flight was Boeing's final
milestone before it was to begin
launching astronauts into space sometime
next year
today's setback could well put that
schedule and
pree yeah right mark thank you very much
it's a reminder that it is hard yeah get
off of this planet yes anything yes
takes a lot of research and a lot of
work and people keep doing it yeah
slowly but surely yeah
all right thank you mark